jedenfalls war schlau auf dem klo nicht
abzuschließen und wer sich da saß kam
plötzlich der gitarrist werfer selbst
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video wir haben ja wie wenn ich in einem
video vor drei tagen zumal eure
reinlichen geschichten und höchste lesen
und geschockt was euch zu passierten am
leben das sich sehr gut gefallen
deswegen gibt heute eine praktische wie
immer ist das formular wieder weltstars
einschicken volt als zweiter link in der
beschreibung hatten wir jetzt so wie
immer jetzt erzählt er da erzählst du
auch ein café auf zwei mal du erzählt
viermal mehr erzählen kann sich das
doppel aber die erste einstellung halten
was ich in zwei freundinnen drehten zum
spaß ein video in welchem zwei von uns
in einem busch gegangen sind direkt
neben einer geldanlage typ war und dort
sehr lauten geräusche gemacht haben die
andere freunde hat dass währenddessen
gefilmt auch mit dem typen drauf
daraufhin rannten ihr geld aus dem bus
und wissen dass der typ bereits nicht
mehr auf der skateranlage baslern direkt
vor uns und an strafe möchte von allen
guten geistern verlassen der farc alter
warum macht man sowas warum rentner in
busch im achter stimmen geräusche er hat
jahre junge ist oder was man in welche
praxen aber wir haben wir auch gemacht
bei den vorhaben du bist wenn du drei
bürgerbusch geradestehen klar gibts
schon auch gut aber wenn leute sich
schon rum lunge so auf das geld der bahn
wieder optisch nicht reinpassen
wirklichkeit supporten backwerk gar
nicht vollzeit arbeiten kommissioniert
weiß schon wo studium gespräche
du weißt schon mehr geld aufnehmen
können du weißt schon der nächste
geschichte etwa ein neuer lehrer unserer
schule die niemand leiden konnte er hat
bei uns so eine lehr prüfung der
unterricht machen musste und hinten darf
drei prüfer unser rektor inklusive
dürfen
ich habe gute morgendlichen beklagt ich
hab mich ich freue mich sehr heute alle
waren eben keiner leiden kann und er
meinte ich laut sagen ja wir wollen aber
nicht auf wie also bitte kurz und
schmerzlos und hauen sie ab da weniger
mega asozial alter warum macht man so
gut ich mein ich selbst war auch dass du
mit mir sicher nicht viel
überhaupt eine richtige beleidigung
diebstahl versucht einfach seinen job
nicht zu verlieren und sein trio besser
verzichten auf geld
sehr schön wie passieren andauernd
unglaubliche dinge zum beispiel habe ich
letztens in der schule so getan als
würde ich hart übels absacken und
verrecken packen müssen kleine abrücken
und hektik öffentlichen schule den
leuten alles cool verlud wissen
vermittelt den jüngsten versuch
[Musik]
bergauf bergab jungs von haber mitbürger
den stuhl gelegt und die übelsten luft
gemacht ja apple hat natürlich nicht
gemerkt dass der lehre stunde zwei
minuten im film entstand warum tut man
soll 5 1 sterben hilfsschule wir haben
gerade weiteren partien kindergeburtstag
1000 als wenn du mir ein bisschen
stiftend gekriegt das waren dass der
vergabe 10 12 jährigen er habe versucht
sie zu entsorgen ist in deutschland
helfen wirklich hat der antwort katalog
in der infobox geschichte ruft couchepin
mit 25 männer in ein junger alter
deutscher in dieser zeit immer mit einem
fach hat mich früh gefahr dann kommt
dieser junge auf mich zu mit ein paar an
den meilern beschlossen kommt auch die
zu und meinte hessischen ried bin dachte
ich er mein fahrer ab dann geantwortet
ich weiß ist gebraucht was den letzten
geschichte ist einfach so geschichten
die keinem normalen menschen im leben
was mir besser das hat jetzt gemeint wir
brauchen hilfe gebraucht wird der hand
gebraut weg entfernt ist ja auch im
trend weil die meisten mädels und jungs
sind ja eigentlich um secondhand manche
mehr oder wenige gebrauchsspuren
er wird über beide firmen rannte der
besitzer für das ja ich war ein jahr in
amerika habe natürlich meine gattin
luise die band ort hamburg kennengelernt
also die musik nicht die jungs selber
jeden fall wird wieder mit mir auch ein
konzert von denen das war voll aber ich
musste während die vorwärts spielte auf
chloride einige von der sparte dürfte
ich backstage aktion musste mich nicht
vorne anstellen das war ein richtiger
körbchen feichtenschlager auf dem klo
nicht abzuschließen und werde ich das
komplett der gitarrist mein absoluter
liebling aus der während rein und guck
nicht dummes ich war auf dem herrenklo
ich kann hier muss ich bis heute nicht
mehr hören ohne mich zu stehen während
wir den fiktiven ohne das eigentlich
schon recht nah dabei bisher
verheimlichte werde mich im verlauf der
fans
mit drei youtube wird eingefangen und
noch zwei eseln und einem leguan food
kette quick step up leute geht weiter
mit einer geschichte die die herzen
erwärmt eine geschichte die menschen
berührt männchen hüpft nicht vergessen
deine geschichte von liebe eine
geschichte so flüge der grundschule als
dieser von der größe der arbeit in einem
jugend verlief 2010 gegeben um ein
liebes richtig schreiben eigentlich war
das einzige das drauf stand nur eine art
milch für gaststätten und sagt wir
bitten meinem navi stellte sich wollte
klappte die schaut mal was marie mit
gegeben hat wo menschen existenz nämlich
abstoßen bedeutet das heutige video ein
bisschen kürzer bei macht muss man sich
mal hinfahren wir haben bisher 34 939
einstellung durch also leute es werden
wahrscheinlich ums leben 40 gefordert
daumen nach oben
seit kurzer zeit und das nicht mal geld